Alicia Keys is not the right fit to be
the creative director for blackberry I
mean that was obviously blackberry
trying a last-ditch attempt to see who
its celebrity can get attached to to do
something I mean that that that's not
fair I mean Alicia Keys did that but it
wasn't necessarily she was set up to
fail the roulette I guess that's what I
don't understand like how do we
understand what relationships are set up
to fail and where the partnership is
gonna be golden but I actually think
what Connie said earlier explains the
BlackBerry one very well which is that
company didn't have the right principles
for an artist like that to make
something like that work and that you
know they had spent the last several
years resisting the future and denying
like what had just happened and so you
get the company to that point you're not
in a place where where you're gonna kind
of pull it out in that way so it has to
be the artist has to be authentic or the
or the creative person has to be
authentic but the company's got to be
authentic - and and you know blackberry
had just been a company that lost their
way and actually an Emmy look and saying
Alicia Keys is the creative director of
a technology company yes that's not a
believable idea either
no I mean that's just not believe me
what do you want me to say this stuff
it's like everybody in trouble like I
mean I think it's just obvious is this
ridiculous to have like
you know to just give someone a crew
anyone that particularly Alicia Keys but
just any you know celebrity a creative
director role of anything it says only
you know but maybe I'm thinking not
thinking of a couple but there's only
like three guys that I think could even
possibly work
you know consistently an end that's Ryan
Leslie me and will.i.am because we care
about it you know like we're you know
we're inside of it